[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré au procès du massacre du 28
septembre 2009 en Guinée Conakry ce
jour-là des militaires ont tué plus de
150 personnes et violées sans neuf
femmes lors d'un rassemblement de
l'opposition au stade de Conakry
massacre violent exaction se sont
poursuivies les jours suivants contre
des femmes séquestrées et des détenus
torturés une immense scène de crime le
capitaine Moussa Dadis Camara et dix
autres anciens officielles doivent
répondre d'assassinat de violences
sexuelles et d'enlèvements la commission
d'enquête de l'ONU impute au capitaine
Camara une responsabilité criminelle
personnelle et une responsabilité de
commandement ses proches affirment au
contraire qu'il veut laver son honneur
l'ancien président est plusieurs
coaccusé ont été envoyés en prison hier
avant leur jugement ils vont y rester
jusqu'à la fin du procès c'est le
premier procès de cet ampleur en Guinée
Conakry alors est-ce un procès pour
l'histoire les victimes seront-elles
indemnisées que s'est-il passé ce 28
septembre 2009 quelle leçon peut-on en
tirer en Guinée Conakry et dans le reste
de l'Afrique on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés Patrick Beaudoin bonsoir vous êtes
avocat et président d'honneur de la FIDH
bienvenue dans le débat en face de vous
Christophe Boisbouvier bonsoir
Christophe bonsoir Stéphanie de RFI
chargée d'Afrique vous connaissez
évidemment parfaitement l'Afrique merci
d'être avec nous Christophe Tanguy Bihan
bonsoir journaliste à Afrique 21 merci
d'être là donc dans le débat nous avons
en duplex de Conakry Alimatou Camara
bonsoir à vous avocate des parties
civils militants des droits de l'Homme
également bienvenue oui bonsoir
nous avons également à côté de vous
justement du texte de Conakry PP Antoine
Lama avocat de Moussa Dadis Camara
bonsoir à vous et bienvenue également
dans le débat
[Musique]
que s'est-il que s'est-il passé le 28
septembre 2009 et quel est l'enjeu de ce
procès on fait d'abord un point en
images
le 23 décembre 2008 quelques heures à
peine après la mort du président guinéen
lançana conté le capitaine Moussa Dadis
Camara prend le pouvoir par un coup
d'État très vite il promet
l'organisation d'élections et assure
qu'il ne s'y présentera pas un
engagement sur lequel il revient petit à
petit dans les mois qui suivent comme
dans cette interview dans son lit au
camp militaire de Yao siège de son
gouvernement
deviendra un État démocratique pour le
moment si je dois être candidat si je ne
dois pas être candidat je sais pas ce
qui m'intéresse je suis le père de la
nation c'est ce que le décès aussi a
voulu l'opposition décide alors
d'organiser une grande manifestation le
28 septembre 2009 anniversaire du
référendum de l'indépendance de la
Guinée pour marquer le coup elle choisit
le plus grand stade de Konakry et il
maintient le rassemblement malgré son
interdiction par le gouvernement face à
une foule de près de 50 000 personnes
les bérets rouges de la gare de
présidentielle et la police ça donne tu
as une répression sanglante 156
personnes sont tuées selon l'ONU 109
femmes violées par des militaires
au lendemain du massacre Moussa Dadis
Camara ni toute responsabilité il assure
avoir perdu le contrôle de l'armée
à un général dire que je contrôle cette
armée ce serait de la démagogie Moussa
Dadis Camara est renversé quelques mois
plus tard il fut vers le Burkina Faso où
il passe plus de dix années en exil
l'ancien président dit aujourd'hui
vouloir laver son honneur il s’est rendu
de lui-même à la justice guinéenne à ses
côtés dix autres anciens responsables
dans le gouvernement de la jeune
comparaisse pour les exactions commises
le 28 septembre 2009
je vous propose maintenant d'écouter des
témoignages de victimes au micro de nos
envoyés spéciaux à Conakry
toujours parce que là on se rappelle de
l'événement à chaque année le jour J on
se rappelle de l'événement du 28
septembre on se rappelle de ce qui s'est
passé on se rappelle aussi de ceux-là
qui n'ont pas retrouvé leur mot et ceux
qui sont décédés ça nous rappelle une
douloureuse événement la justice qui
reconnaissent c'est qu'ils ont fait
parce que c'est une chose qu'ils n'ont
jamais fait d'abord
moi la première des choses comme ces
gens-là reconnaissent ils ont été au
stade
ils étaient là ils ont violé ils ont tué
s'il reconnaît ça c'est un premier
victoire
s'il ne reconnaissent pas c'est autre
chose parce que là
nous nous savons qu'on est victime et
s'il est bourreaux ne reconnaissent pas
ça ça va être aussi difficile
vraiment stupéfiant vous pouvez réagir
sur les réseaux sociaux sur le hashtag
débat F24 Christophe Boisbouvier pour
bien cadrer un peu le débat c'est le
premier procès de ce type en Guinée
Conakry il faut rappeler qu'il y a tout
un ensemble de de d'acteurs
internationaux présents donc ça soit
l'ONU la CPI qui sont en fait
observateurs enquêteurs est-ce que c'est
un procès fiable
ça a été d'abord d'une cruauté
incroyable indicible et très très vite
il y a une commission internationale
dirigée par l'ONU qui a pu faire un
premier constat terrible sur les au
moins 156 personnes tuées et les au
moins 109 femmes violées je dis bien au
moins parce que malheureusement beaucoup
de femmes par peur d'être stigmatisées
non pas dit ensuite qu'elles ont été
violées donc on se doute que c'est
beaucoup de c'est un chiffre beaucoup
plus important
et donc à la suite de ça il y a cette
commission qui est allée travailler et
qui a dit les choses et à partir de là
d'un disque Camara a été grivant blessé
par l'un des principaux adjoints qui
lui-même avait participé au crime et qui
se retrouve dans le box avec lui
aujourd'hui il a été renversé et on a
cru que le procès aurait lieu assez vite
à ce moment-là parce qu'il y a eu un
vent de démocratie qui a soufflé sur la
Guinée Malo en 2009 ouais on est en 2009
arrive Alpha Condé il est élu démoc
uniquement en 2010 on pense que ça y est
le procès va pouvoir malheureusement
pendant les les
2021 les 11 années de régime d'Alpha
Condé il se passe rien parce que un
certain nombre des tortionnaires de 2009
sont toujours présents dans le la
hiérarchie militaire du régime d'Alpha
Condé et on arrive avec ce putsch qui
renverse Alpha Condé en 2000 en 2021 et
avec donc un autre militaire au pouvoir
c'est ça le paradoxe le paradoxe on va
reparler bien sûr le colonel mamada on a
aujourd'hui ce procès donc on peut
espérer que que ça va être un procès où
toutes les choses vont être dites c'est
pour ça que
le Karim Kahn le procureur de la CPI est
venu ce mercredi à Conakry maintenant
est-ce que ce sera un vrai procès ou
est-ce que ce sera un procès plein de
faux semblant c'est la grande question
ça reste une question donc c'est ce que
vous dites ce soir Patrick Baudoin la
FIDH est présente sur se passe vous avez
fait en tant que que protection
fondation protecteur des droits de
l'homme il y a eu un rapport accablant
en tout cas qui qualifie carrément les
faits de crimes contre l'humanité ça va
jusque là oui ça va jusque là mais c'est
en concordant avec ce qui vient d'être
rappelé de la vie de la commission des
Nations Unies ce qu'il faut souligner
mais je rejoins le propos on est partagé
aujourd'hui entre espérance et
satisfaction de voir le process Tony
mais une certaine inquiétude et
appréhension sur son déroulement
c'est tout ceci remonte à très années il
faut quand même le rappeler et victime
raisonner que les victimes attendent et
c'est là le point essentiel d'ailleurs à
retenir et il y a eu des avancées
judiciaires il y a eu un juge
d'instruction en particulier dans les
premières années qui a fini par faire un
travail important qui avait on va dire à
peu près bouclé le dossier en 2004 la
struction elle est terminée complètement
depuis 2007 nous sommes 2017 pardon nous
sommes maintenant nous sommes maintenant
en 2022 donc il y a eu 5 ans là pendant
lesquelles rien ne s'est passé et puis
c'est dans une certaine précipitation il
faut le dire maintenant que le procès se
tient il a été annoncé dernièrement et
alors certes il y a un nouveau palais de
justice qui a été édifié mais on voit le
retour de Dadis Camara qui vient de
rentrer dans le pays
au Burkina il était en exil au Burkina
Faso ses avocats commencent à dire il a
été incarcéré c'est pas normal on n'a
pas eu accès à tous les éléments du
dossier parce que ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est que tout à la fois il
faut bien entendu un procès qui
satisface les attentes de des victimes
de ce massacre abominable mais qui
respecte aussi les règles du droit au
procès équitable de façon à ce que ce ne
soit pas une parodie de justice
donc il faut trouver cet équilibre
absolument pour que le process soit
exemplaire et j'ajouterai simplement
malheureusement dans le passé dans en
Guinée comme dans d'autres pays
africains on a vu des avancées
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une revendication
de justice et ça c'est un point positif
mais très souvent elle se trouve une
finie en travée et on a beaucoup de mal
à parvenir à la finalisation d'une
véritable justice indépendance
indépendante impartiale respectée Camara
bouquet l'avocate des parties civils en
direct de Conakry avec nous vous pouvez
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
peut-être justement Patrick Baudouin
d'abord qu'est-ce que vous attendez vous
de ce procès d'abord des réparations
pour les victimes ou autre chose
oui en effet ce procès est un procès
historique
et je pense que les victimes attendent
des réparations mais elles attendent
également des reconnus
en tant que victime et ça c'est
extrêmement important de le souligner
aujourd'hui on se pose la question
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup d'expérience
il y a beaucoup d'espoir
mais la question fondamentale c'est
voilà on veut les dégages d'une justice
qui soit juste et équitable
vous avez dit je voudrais la fin de
l'impunité et pour toutes les parties au
procès
oui effectivement là surtout pour la fin
de l'impunité je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
y a il y a la question de la mémoire
collective dans notre pays
qui est extrêmement important
nous avons un pays qui a connu beaucoup
de répression sanglante
et les événements de 2009 sont venus un
peu couronnés
un système d'impunité
qui existe depuis plus de 60 ans depuis
que ce pays existe
donc là pour la première fois il
pourrait y avoir justement réparation on
a
oui pour la première fois il pourrait
avoir réparation mais au-delà de la
réparation on s'achemine
on s'achemine vraiment vers la
construction de ce qu'est un État de
droit
donc c'est un enjeu fondamental qui
était replacées à un moment donné
aujourd'hui son jugés je pense que c'est
c'est un symbole qui est fort et il
faudrait que ce procès devienne un gage
que ça ne reste pas simplement dans les
symboles
pépé Antoine Lama vous êtes avocat vous
de Moussa Dadis Camara merci aussi
d'être avec nous la commission d'enquête
de l'ONU impute au capitaine Camara une
responsabilité criminelle personnelle et
une responsabilité de commandement
est-il responsable du massacre
le capitaine
des crimes qu'on lui reproche je
commence par rappeler que le capitaine
ne sait jamais en vue vers Ouagadougou
il y a été contraint par la communauté
internationale à travers une procédure
inédite et après
les événements du 28 septembre
souvenez-vous que le président Moussa
Dadis Camara
intéressé préoccuper par l'idée de faire
la lumière sur ces événements à tout de
suite mis en place une commission
d'enquête nationale qui a mené un
travail sur trois mois entre temps il
lui a été imposé une commission
d'enquête internationale qui est venu
s'approprier des activités des militants
pour incriminer le capitaine Moussa
Dadis camarade et souvenez-vous que
cette commission d'enquête
internationale n'a fait que une semaine
à Conakry contrairement à la commission
d'enquête nationale qui a fait au moins
trois mois mais aujourd'hui dans tous
les médias surtout les trois on impute
la responsabilité de ses événements au
capitaine
sur le fondement de ce rapport qui
comporte assez de contradiction donc
la chance est enfin donné
la chance est en train de donner au
capitaine Moussa Dadis Camara délivrer
sa part de vérité depuis 13 ans il n'a
fait que réclamer la tenue de ce procès
depuis 13 ans il a demandé à retourner
au pays pour livrer sa part de vérité
ce sont les autorités d'abord qui ne lui
ont pas donné le 7 opportunité donc
aujourd'hui donc c'est l'heure pour lui
de laver son honneur son intégrité qui
ont été souhaits par ces accusations
qu'on sa personne qui ne se repousse
aucun élément probable le seul crime
aujourd'hui du capitaine Moussa Dadis
Camara c'est d'avoir été chef de l'État
et commandant en chef des forces armées
pensez-vous que ces deux fonctions la
constitue en soi une infraction est-ce
que cette commission d'enquête nationale
je vais faire rebondir justement des
invités sur le plateau également ici
Tanguy bien qui n'a pas encore pris la
parole comment est-ce qu'on en est
arrivé à un tel massacre et est-ce
qu'effectivement donc là on voit bien
que pépé Antoine Lama conteste la
responsabilité du capitaine mais est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en fait
comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là
il faut savoir que en fait ce procès
même s'il a eu une ampleur inédite au vu
des dégâts c'est à dire le massacré
froyable qui a eu les nombreux viols les
milliers de blessés en fait ça s'inscrit
dans un contexte important en Guinée il
faut savoir que déjà en 2007 à la fin du
régime de l'ancienne à compter en deux
mois il y avait eu plus de 130
manifestants qui avaient été tués sous
les balles de des forces de défense et
de sécurité donc en fait ça s'inscrit
dans un contexte répressif important qui
même si on a atteint entre guillemets le
summum au moment du massacre du 28
septembre 2009 il faut savoir que ça a
perdurer en fait soit Alpha Condé et
notamment la répression du Front
national pour la défense de la
Constitution et même avant les élections
intermédiaires et encore aujourd'hui
sous le CNRD
mais quand l'avocat Christophe bois
Bouvier quand justement TP Antoine Lama
conteste le travail finalement de cette
commission des droits de l'homme est-ce
qu'il a raison est-ce qu'elle a eu le
temps de travailler effectivement
c'était tangible les différentes preuves
on les rapports sont quand même
accablants il y a eu un travail sérieux
fait par cette commission qui est venue
pour l'ONU à partir de multiples
témoignages qui ont été recueillis avec
l'aide notamment
des organisations de droits de l'homme
qui sont sur place je pense notamment à
l'organisation guinéenne des droits de
l'homme qui est je crois maître affilié
à la fidh1 si je me souviens bien il
faut saluer le travail des défenseurs
des droits de l'homme en Guinée Conakry
grâce à ce travail l'ONU a pu faire ce
rapport
ce que dit Tanguy est exact c'est-à-dire
que ce que dit maître Alimatou Camara
est malheureusement exacte c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une véritable culture de
l'impunité
qui date en fait des années
s'écoutourées à partir de l'indépendance
et du nom à de Gaulle le pays se referme
sur lui-même à cause notamment des
Français d'ailleurs qui qui tentent de
renverser ses coûts des Portugais
ensuite donc ces coûts s'enferment dans
une sorte de paranoïa qui aboutit au
premier grand massacre en Guinée dans
les années 70 avec notamment ce sinistre
quand dans lequel les prisonniers
meurent littéralement de faim des
milliers de prisonniers meurent sous la
férule de sékourées et puis notamment
dialotelli le grand Diallo Telli et puis
arrive après la mort de Sékou Touré en
84 les militaires qui prennent le
pouvoir littéralement et qui prennent
leur revanche sur un régime marxiste en
s'installant dans un régime de prédation
de de d'omnipotence et qui prennent en
effet cette culture de l'impunité
tout leur est permis la prévarication la
corruption mais aussi le crime en 2007
en 2009 et encore ensuite dans les
années 2010 et jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais
quand on parle justement de la
responsabilité de Moussa D10 Camara
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Patrick
Beaudoin qu'on remet en cause comme
vient de faire son avocat un peu les
travaux la Commission des droits de
l'homme ce que je pense c'est que c'est
le rôle de son avocat de de défendre
Dadis Camara
c'est ce que dit ses proches c'est lavé
la raison pour laquelle il serait rentré
du Burkina alors qu'il aurait pu y
rester ça s'il procès peut être mené à
son terme et de façon équitable c'est la
justice qui le dira donc moi je prendrai
pas parti là-dessus en revanche je
rebondis sur ce qui vient d'être dit
c'est-à-dire il y a pas eu seulement le
travail de la commission des Nations
Unies il y a eu sur place les défenseurs
des droits de l'Homme les avocats il y a
eu la Fédération internationale des
droits de l'homme qui en Guinée a été
extrêmement présente et qui a quand même
un savoir-faire en matière aussi
d'enquête d'audition d'investigation
et puis il y a quand même une
instruction qui a eu lieu en Guinée avec
je le rappelais des injuses
d'instruction des auditions de victimes
de parties civiles donc il y a tout un
dossier comme dans tout procès pénal qui
a pu être constitué donc les éléments à
charge Cora a apprécier la juridiction
saisie ne repose pas seulement sur le
rapport de la commission des Nations
Unies c'est tout un ensemble d'éléments
moi je rappellerai simplement pour ce
qui concerne ce Camara c'est une défense
classique qu'on trouve dans beaucoup de
pays moi j'ai fréquenté beaucoup de
juridictions au Cambodge et ailleurs
évidemment il y a une défense c'est
d'ailleurs normal mais c'est un petit
peu la négation des responsabilités il
était quand même chef d'État il a été
rappelé tout à l'heure qu'il était chef
des forces armées et dans un climat de
violence qui est entretenu qui a été
entretenu
lorsqu'il a été à la tête du pays qui
malheureusement a continué à l'être et à
chaque fois où il y a
une nouvelle arrivant qui prend les
responsabilités du pays c'est pour dire
on va nettoyer les écuries on va
maintenant mettre un terme à l'impunité
que ça soit la corruption que ça soit
les violences et puis très très vite on
retombe sur les erreurs du passé donc ce
qu'il faut souligner aujourd'hui
puisqu'on est avec ce procès c'est qu'il
est parce qu'il faut donner quand même
une note d'optimisme et il y en a eu une
pour les victimes c'est qu'il est en
train de s'ouvrir alors il faut qu'il
aille à son terme il faut appuyer
absolument
la justice pour qu'elle puisse
équitablement donner satisfaction aux
victimes rendre la vérité et puis
statuer de manière impartiale sur les
responsabilités des uns et des autres et
y compris de de l'ancien président ou
responsable puisqu'il avait un titre un
peu différent d'un disque Amara on
redonner un peu de contexte actuel
tanguyant le procès intervient donc on
vous l'aurait appelé Christophe dans un
contexte de tension avec justement ce
coup d'État qui a eu lieu il y a un an
du colonel ma des forces spéciales qui
ont renversé le chef de l'état alpha
Condé donc c'était le 5 septembre 2021
Alpha Condé a reporté effectivement ce
procès pourquoi est-ce que Doumbouya a
décidé de le maintenir pourquoi ça a
lieu maintenant
déjà il faut expliquer pourquoi Alpha
Condé n'a pas fait le procès il avait eu
le temps de le faire en demandant plus
il s'est rajouté un an en essayant de
faire un troisième mandat auquel ce
n'est pas arrivé à terme
l'instruction a été clôturée en 2017
comme ça a été dit donc déjà c'est
quelque chose qui a salué mais il faut
savoir que ça a été clôturé sous la
pression de la Cour pénale
internationale c'est-à-dire que la Cour
pénale internationale avec qualifié à la
suite en fait en suivant le rapport des
Nations Unies de de potentiel crime
contre l'humanité et donc c'était
impliqué dans le dossier la compagnie
internationale envoyait des missions
chaque année et en fait c'est sous cette
pression que Alpha Condé étant donné la
situation malheureusement de la justice
en Guinée
a fait a pu faire avancer l'instruction
et en fait Alpha Condé a dû d'un côté
donner des gages à la campagne
internationale et d'un autre côté ne pas
faire pas faire haut avancer
l'instruction en quelque sorte pour ne
pas s'aligner l'armée qui pouvait le
renverser qui d'ailleurs a fini par leur
renverser donc au contraire lui laisse
faire alors que lui aussi est arrivé par
un coup d'État lui aussi est un
militaire même si c'est une autre
génération oui pourquoi je pense qu'il y
a quelque chose comme un effet d'aubaine
en fait pour lui c'est-à-dire que
Doumbouya est en train de vouloir se
construire une sorte de légitimité
internationale sachant que la Guinée a
été sanctionné par la Cedeao des
sanctions progressives depuis six jours
donc au niveau international la Guinée
aujourd'hui se retrouve en difficulté
sachant que les États-Unis on fait une
déclaration en approuvant les sanctions
de la CEDEAO et donc
étant donné également les crimes qui ont
été commis il faut rappeler que le 5
septembre la jungle guinéenne n'a pas
communiqué là-dessus il y a eu des mort
des dizaines de morts lors du coup
d'État il n'y a pas eu d'enquête il y a
eu des recettes de cadavres et donc
aujourd'hui Doumbouya doit se racheter
une image et si lancent le procès il
pourra mettre ça dans son actif en
disant qu'il se soucie des droits de
l'homme et des crimes contre l'humanité
vous êtes d'accord à Christophe oui
alors il y a une situation paradoxale
parce que vous avez d'un côté les
militaires du CNRD avec le colonel
Doumbouya qui fonce ce geste historique
de de laisser ce procès démarrer ce
mercredi et de l'autre vous avez quand
même deux des principaux leaders de
l'opposition et de la société civile
faut [__] phonique et Mangué et
Ibrahima Diallo qui sont des leaders du
fndc le Front national pour la défense
de la Constitution lequel a été dissout
il y a deux mois vous avez ces deux
leaders qui sont en prison vous avez eu
plusieurs morts en juillet et en août au
moins 5 morts à l'issue de la répression
de deux grosses manifestations dans
Conakry donc vous avez cette situation
très paradoxale ou côté vous avez ce
grand geste d'ouverture et de l'autre
vous avez
ces loups dans la Diallo le principal
leader de l'opposition qui est en exil
de fait à Dakar parce que la situation
est trop difficile pour lui animatou
Camara pour en revenir justement au
victime moi ce que j'ai lu c'était
absolument terrifiant plusieurs
témoignages qui rapportent comment les
bérets rouges sont entrés dans
l'enceinte on bouclé les accès ont
ouvert le feu sans discrimination sur
une foule festive et des armée des
hommes qui ensuite ont poursuivi leurs
besogne au couteau à la machette à la
baïonnette
jonchon les cadavres sur la pelouse
manifestement des cadavres ont disparu
enfin c'est vraiment effectivement une
scène terrible de crime qui est décrite
là
oui c'est malheureusement
c'est effroyable c'est innommable ce qui
s'est passé au stade du 28 septembre et
c'est pas seulement au stade du 28
septembre c'est les jours aussi qui ont
suivi il y a eu de la séquestration il y
a eu des viols il y a eu des
disparitions forcées
et c'est bien d'ailleurs de revenir sur
le rapport d'enquête nationale dans mon
confrère pépé Antoine Lama se prévaut
quand d'une dissimulation de preuve
dissimulation de cadavre recèle de
cadavre c'est c'est extraordinaire parce
que on nous parle de 57 morts d'après le
rapport de cette commission nationale
d'enquête alors qu'on a qu'on a des
disparu qu'on a des disparu et mon
confrère explique également qu'ils ont
eu trois mois pour faire ce travail il y
a eu aucune
aucune arrestation aucun semblant
d'arrestation
personne n'était responsable n'était
coupable de quoi que ce soit c'est juste
hallucinant de dire que monsieur Moussa
Dadis Camara était le président du CNDD
il était le chef de l'État à l'époque il
ne contrôlait peut-être pas les choses
le jour du 28 septembre mais et les
jours qui ont suivi ils ont eu le temps
de faire le rapport dans tête
je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'heure est à la
vérité et je pense que tous les acteurs
qui sont impliqués dans dans ce procès
que ce soit les victimes que ça soit
ceux qui sont présumés auteurs ou auteur
ou complices dans cette affaire je pense
qu'on doit avoir de la hauteur pour
l'histoire de notre pays on doit avoir
de la responsabilité dans ce que nous
déclarons devant les médias
parce que ce qui s'est passé n'est pas
acceptable ce qui s'est passé ne devrait
pas être cautionné par aucune société
normale
un mot sur ces victimes aujourd'hui je
pense que les victimes attendent elles
attendent d'être attendu elles attendent
d'être reconnus reconnus dans leur
statut de victime parce que ça également
c'est thérapeutique dans ce procès là
est-ce qu'elles vont défiler les unes
après les autres à partir d'aujourd'hui
plus de 13 ans
oui oui aujourd'hui je pense que la peur
a changé de camp la peur a changé de
camp et aussi le pouvoir et tout ce qui
entoure le mythe du pouvoir ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut souligner
également c'est que ceux qui viennent
aux affaires ont intérêt à faire les
choses en respectant les droits de
l'homme parce que tôt ou tard on est on
est rattrapé et ça je le dis en pensant
en contact actuellement de notre pays
qui est également un contexte transition
est-ce que vous avez peur justement on a
tous intérêt aujourd'hui qui est une
vérité judiciaire est-ce que vous avez
peur justement que le procès capote
compte tenu du contexte actuel qu'on
vient de décrire ici
mais je pense que
on a peur parce que la justice guinéenne
n'est pas voilà une justice que nous
applaudissons tous les jours donc
aujourd'hui la justice elle est elle est
au défi de elle doit relever le défi
malheureusement nous avons perdu la
connexion avec Conakry cette animatou
camarade donc qui était qui avocat des
parties civils que vous venez que vous
venez d'entendre on peut vraiment
vraiment rebondir là dessus Patrick
Baudoin ce qu'elle a dit justement sur
les victimes et puis tout de même cette
peur qu'elle a que ça n'aille pas au
bout parce qu'effectivement on est dans
ce contexte politique compliqué qu'on a
commencé à décrire pas facile de se dire
que le procès ira jusqu'au bout ce
procès qu'elle qualifie bien historique
oui oui c'est un procès historique ça
moi je reprends le terme mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a un paradoxe parce qu'on a une
jointe qui est au pouvoir qui est une
jeune qui continue de de d'avoir des
pratiques autoritaires et de violation
des droits de l'homme et qu'il a essaye
de se refaire une un début de virginité
en mettant en place ce procès mais c'est
fragile d'une part d'autre part pour les
victimes il y a tout de même un souci
majeur c'est qu'elle soit bien protégée
qu'il n'y ait pas de risque pour leur
sécurité et qu'elle
il faut que ce soit le cas pour qu'elles
aient une liberté de parole
d'expression c'est là où on va voir
c'est là où on va voir s'il y a une
vraie volonté de tenir un procès qui
respecte tous les droits se dit victime
se désacuser et avec cette possibilité
et c'est vrai qu'on a des craintes
là-dessus je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est un énorme espoir puisque le procès
démarre et ça pour les victimes très en
attente c'est formidable ça nous a été
très bien dit par l'avocat de ces
parties civils qui s'est exprimé et on
ne peut pas ne pas avoir une une
certaine crainte sur la tenue de ce
procès dans le contexte où il se trouve
qui est un contexte qui reste éminemment
politique il faut que ce procès
réussisse nous le souhaitons nous nous
appuyons en ce sens si un fond
d'indemnisation c'est pas qui a été créé
c'est aussi une bonne chose mais par qui
sera-t-il alimenté quel sera le montant
est-ce qu'il y aura raisonnablement au
fond ou pas
et qui met l'argent dans le fond enfin
il y a une opacité qui continue
subsister on a le sentiment qu'on a
voulu là de la part du pouvoir donner
des gages à la communauté internationale
à l'extérieur peut-être aussi à la CPI
qui continue de surveiller de très près
puisque si le procès ne peut avoir lieu
en Guinée la CPI a toujours dit c'est
nous qui reprenons la main car ça peut
être du ressort de la Cour pénale
internationale si la justice nationale
qui est la justice guinéenne ne veut pas
ou ne peut pas juger donc je pense qu'il
y a un équilibre qui reste extrêmement
fragile et que il faut voir si ce procès
va se tenir s'il n'y a pas un renvoi
s'il se renvoie ne sera pas dilatoire
nous espérons simplement qu'il se
tiennent je le redis et qui est vraiment
un signal fort qui soit donné en Guinée
qui est un pays qui n'a connu que
l'impunité de lutte contre l'impunité
qui serait exemplaire aussi pour des
pays voisins qui continuent également de
pratiquer cette impunité
vous faire intervenir mais d'abord je
voudrais qu'on voit justement un extrait
de l'interview vous avez fait avec Marc
peyrolman c'était la semaine dernière à
l'occasion de l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies vous avez interviewé le
président de la CEDEAO qui le président
de Guinée-Bissau et voilà ce qu'il a dit
avec lequel c'est le plus compliqué
c'est la Guinée vous y êtes allé vous
avez demandé un chronogramme de 2 ans
pour une transition la jante dit non
c'est trois ans on ne bougera pas est-ce
que là on a un blocage complet non non
pas de blocage je pense pas que les gens
t'as dit que les 3 ans j'ai pas entendu
ça je n'ai pas il l'aurait affirme non
ça je pense que donc il y a une
compréhension de ça ça c'est une
acceptable pour la CEDEAO inacceptable
et négociable ça veut dire que si la
jante maintient 3 ans là pour le coup il
y aurait des sanctions absolument
absolument
Christophe donc un pays sous sanctions
de la dernière chance avant d'arriver au
sanctions
vous avez un médiateur qui s'appelle
l'ancien président du Bénin Bonnie qui a
beaucoup de mal d'ailleurs c'est
difficile pour lui vous avez un colonel
à la tête du
CNRD m'a dit Doumbouya qui est vraiment
déterminé à ce que la transition dure
trois ans pas une semaine de moins
disent ses proches donc il y a vraiment
une position ferme de sa part il a pas
du tout aimé l'interview que vous venez
dont vous venez de passer un extrait il
a pas du tout aimé les propos de son
voisin Sissoko Mballo de Guinée-Bissau
il a fait savoir dès le lendemain
vous avez maintenant je pense encore un
terrain d'entente grâce à des médiateurs
comme évidemment Bonnie Yayi comme Macky
Sall le président du Sénégal président
exercice de l'Union africaine
la CEDEAO demande 2 ans qu'on a crié 3
ans il y a peut-être un moyen terme à
trouver
un contexte c'est compliqué parce que je
vous le rappelle donc il y a au moins
deux leaders du fndc qui sont en prison
depuis bientôt deux mois parce que vous
avez beaucoup de leaders de l'opposition
qui sont en exil et alors je retiens
quand même une phrase de Alphonse
Charles right qui est le garde des
sceaux le ministre guinéen de la justice
qui a dit sur RFI il y a deux semaines
les victimes il y a 450 parties civils
450 victimes donc qui sont présentes à
ce process c'est énorme ce procès ça va
durer des semaines et des mois qui
demande à être protégé il a promis sur
RFI que ces personnes seraient protégées
si elles le demandent donc ça vraiment
c'est important très important de la
part du ministre guinéen de la justice
monsieur Wright vous avez cette
déclaration de Karim Kahn le bateau du
procès ne fait que quitter le quai il
faut maintenant qu'il arrive à
destination donc il faut c'est bien mais
il faut rester très vigilant tanguyant
sur cette question justement de la
sécurité du maintien du procès d'un
procès fiable jusqu'au bout
bon sur la question de la sécurité il
faudrait être sur place pour savoir
comment ça se passe concrètement donc on
a créé qu'une ville assez particulière
parce que tout est exigu les gens sont
vraiment les uns à côté des autres dans
les quartiers donc c'est vraiment
contexte très particulier très
militarisé
mais après concernant le procès je pense
que en fait
ça dévoilera également la nature du CNRD
c'est à dire que le déroulé du procès
dévoilera si ça se passe bien peut-être
encore les bonnes intentions du CNRD ce
qui pour le moment est loin d'être
évident alors
ce sera un test en tout cas pour le CNRD
on verra si la justice est indépendante
qui pour l'instant est loin d'être
évident quand on voit
comment des opposants sont mis en prison
comment la cour anticorruption qui a été
montée fonctionne donc c'est aussi au
magistrat
de prouver leur indépendance en prenant
des décisions fortes et de de s'imposer
face à la justice ne doit pas
ne doit pas se laisser
pas courber les Chine elle doit pas
courber les Chine voilà face à la jante
pépé Antoine Lama maître vous êtes
l'avocat de Moussa dédices Camara je le
dis pour ceux qui nous rejoignent quel
est votre sentiment donc vous le
défendez vous pensez qu'il n'est pas
responsable ou le procès le dira est-ce
que vous pensez que ce procès ira
jusqu'au bout
quel est votre
ressentiment je déplore je déplore être
les dans ces débats sur le 4
pardon on a encore on a encore pardon on
a encore un petit problème un petit
problème de connexion avec Conakry j'en
profite
une correction je vous ai dit qu'il y
avait pas de sanction j'ai d'une bêtise
et en fait on a déjà il y a un début de
sanction à titre individuel c'est à dire
que la CEDEAO s'est réuni en
[Musique]
comment dit-on en session extraordinaire
a fait une réunion extraordinaire à New
York jeudi dernier et a décidé qu'il y
aurait des sanctions individuelles pour
un certain nombre de cadres du S7 du
CNRD des militaires du CNRD donc on
n'est pas encore si vous voulez aux
sanctions collectives du type de celles
qui ont été prises contre le Mali au
mois de janvier dernier c'est-à-dire des
sanctions lourdes à caractère économique
commerciale
individuelles individuelles pour
l'instant je ne sais pas si on a à
nouveau la connexion avec Conakry non on
les a perdu définitivement je suis
désolé maître pépé Antoine Lama c'était
au moment où vous êtes exprimé on va
réessayer de vous avoir tout de même il
nous reste 5 minutes d'émissions donc on
a peut-être on aura peut-être une chance
de vous avoir à nouveau
Patrick Baudoin donc voilà on parlait
d'espoir quelles leçons pour être tirer
de ce procès pour l'histoire pour
l'histoire de la Guinée Conakry pour
l'histoire de l'Afrique si le procès va
son terme dans des conditions
satisfaisantes ça serait presque une pas
tout à fait une première bon il y a eu
le procès dissen abré il y a eu d'autres
d'autres procédures qui ont quand même
avancé abouti mais je crois que ça
serait exemplaire effectivement pour la
Guinée certainement qui n'a jamais connu
une véritable justice et je le disais
aussi pour les pays voisins la
Fédération internationale des des droits
humains bon et très très investis sur la
justice dans ce secteur du continent
africain où il y a eu beaucoup d'espoir
parce que beaucoup de demandes de
justice que ce soit au que ce soit en
Côte d'Ivoire et avec une des avocats
des organisations défenses des droits de
l'homme national
des magistrats et puis la plupart de ces
procédures finalement pour des raisons
bien entendu politiques ont été
court-circuités ils ne sont pas allés
jusqu'à leur terre termes donc là si on
peut aller jusqu'au terme
ça serait une victoire dans le cadre
d'un combat essentiel aujourd'hui plus
que jamais qui est celui de la lutte
contre l'impunité et on voit très bien
que c'est un combat mondial la lutte
contre l'impunité on le voit en Ukraine
on le voit en Syrie pour parler d'autres
régions du monde et l'Afrique ne doit
pas rester
ne doit pas demeurer en reste elle a
cette capacité désormais avec tout de
même des progrès qui ont été accomplis
ne serait-ce que dans la formation des
magistrats ou de certains magistrats
donc il faut aller de l'avant et on
espère je le disais avec toutefois
avec aussi quelques inquiétudes qui ont
été rappelés
on a à nouveau la connexion avec Conakry
et lorsque comme on a effectivement
interrompu l'avocat de Moussa Dadis
caméra pépé Antoine lamas est-ce que
vous m'entendez vous étiez en train de
dire on parlait justement est-ce que ce
procès ira jusqu'au bout vous avez
encore un petit peu de temps on espère
que la connexion va durer cette fois je
vous disais que l'avocat de Moussa Dadis
que je suis aisé dans cette émission sur
8t il y a trois qui font des
déclarations à charge mais l'avocat de
Moussa Dadis n'a même pas eu encore même
30 secondes pour s'exprimer mais alors
parler de voilà et de on est en train de
parler du droit à un procès équitable
droit et un procès impartial bref un
procès qui remue ou qui comporte
les standards recherchés au niveau d'une
justice équitable et je ne sais pas ce
que de l'autre côté on appelle un
processus équitable est-ce que le procès
juste équitable veut dire qu'il faut
forcément coûte que coûte vaille entrée
en condamnation à l'égard du capitaine
Moussa Dadis Camara même si il n'y a pas
d'éléments de preuves à charge est-ce
que c'est ce qu'il s'agit nous allons
n'est-ce pas laisser la justice
guinéenne répondre à cette question
Camara c'est qu'en fait il n'a rien fait
après pendant les jours qui ont suivi et
c'est de là qu'elle parlait d'une
responsabilité
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ça quand on
parle de ce qui s'est passé après mais
on est en train de parler de crimes qui
ont été commis qui aurait été commis
n'est-ce pas le 28 septembre 2009 et
vous vous parlez des faits qui ont été
commis après le 28 septembre
quand on parle des meurtres des
assassinats des viols de séquestration
des enlèvements et autres ça s'est passé
quand ça s'est passé le 28 septembre
2009 c'est vrai qu'on dit que des
séquestrations ont continué après des
violons continuer après c'est bien beau
de dire tout ça les débats vont révéler
la réalité de ces allégations mais ce
que moi je demande qu'on prouve et c'est
ce que nous allons demander à la barre
c'est la responsabilité pénale de
monsieur Moussa Dadis Camara je rappelle
que le capitaine Moussa Dadis est
poursuivi pour des chefs d'incubation de
complicité de mode
assassinat pillage où est blessé de
volontaire et plusieurs autres
infrasions on reproche au capitaine
Moussa Dali d'avoir donné des ordres et
des instructions à ceux qui auraient
perpétré ces crimes là mais jusqu'à date
les principales figures qui sont
inclinées dans cette affaire ceux-là qui
ont été déclarés visibles au stade du 28
septembre aucune de ces personnes n'a
déclaré avoir été là sur ordre ou
instruction du président Moussa Dadis
Camara aucun témoin aucune victime n'a
encore réussi à apporter la preuve que
le président Moussa Dadis a donné des
instructions des moyens ou des ordres à
qui que ce soit pour perpétrer une
infrasion on se limite tout ça dit il
était le commandant en chef des fausses
armées à l'époque des faits mais soyons
sérieux est-ce que Emmanuel Macron a été
tenu des responsables pour les
infraction pour reprocher au soldats
américains en Afghanistan au Mali
en tout cas en direct de Conakry Merci à
VOUS animatou camarade d'avoir également
été avec nous pardonné nous pour ces
problèmes techniques à d'ailleurs pardon
à tous les deux également puis pardon au
téléspectateur merci beaucoup à
Christophe beaugouvier d'avoir été avec
nous merci Patrick Baudouin et puis
merci Tanguy bean merci à tous d'avoir
suivi cette émission et vous restez avec
nous sur France 24
[Musique]